wichtig bei der bekämpfung von corona
sind die standardmäßigen
hygienemaßnahmen ganz klar unter anderem
sich nicht ins gesicht zu fassen wurde
jetzt gerade schon angesprochen und auch
vom bundesgesundheitsminister noch mal
gerade im bundestag schon gar nicht in
die nähe der nase oder des bundes oder
der augen fassen weil dann geraten die
viren noch einfacher über die
schleimhäute in den körper haben sie
aber schon mal gezählt wie oft sie sich
ins gesicht fassen mein kollege konzern
team weg ist bei mir hat es getestet
heute wir haben dich gefilmt wie du
arbeitest hierbei bild in der redaktion
und haben dann mal gezählt wie oft du
dich ins gesicht gefasst hast wir gucken
mal auf das was wir aufgenommen haben so
zeitraffer da können wir jetzt gar nicht
so doll zählen aber da sieht man schon
mal 56 was glaubst du wie wieviel sind
schnell bewusst ich glaube 789 mal öfter
nicht tja soll dann bist du jetzt schon
drüber bei zwölf silber- und das alles
nur in einer stunde und wird landen dann
letztendlich bei gucken mal und da sieht
man auch eine telefon auch superschön
und wahrscheinlich auch ist das nicht
deinen platz dem platz teil ich mit
kollegen habe natürlich vorher nicht
saubergemacht
also alles falsch gemacht ja hätte
erwartet dass es so oft dass du dir so
oft ins gesicht fest innerhalb einer
stunde
nein unter keinen umständen ich dachte
vielleicht alle zehn minuten
ergo vielleicht fünf sechs mal pro
stunde das ist jetzt wie viele waren es
über 30 über 30 nein damit habe ich
wirklich nicht gerechnet
ich habe mir immerhin vor die hände
gewaschen ja dass das kleiner schwacher
trost
nein ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass
das es so vieles ich glaube das ist
jetzt aber auch sehr schwierig ist wenn
du jetzt sagst okay ich mache das nicht
mehr
das wirklich zu kontrollieren ja ich
habe das ja auch nicht absichtlich
gemacht
das ist halt das passiert einfach so ja
wenn ich auch ans telefon gehe nämlich
ein glas trinke und die monet schon die
hand eh schon im gesicht ist ja dann
geht es natürlich schnell also wir
werden vielleicht morgen von mir hören
ob du es geschafft hast dich zu
kontrollieren ob er den rest des tages
die weniger häufig ins gesicht gefasst
hast wir haben es gut ich bin gespannt
ich drücke die daumen und morgen dein
bericht dann darüber
danke dir constantin